hast du Angst im Leben 100%
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es einen richtig leckeren
Kuchen den werde ich heute allerdings
nicht alleine zubereiten sondern habe
meinen tagespraktikanten da der paul ist
hier um mich zu unterstützen
schön dass ich dabei sein darf also das
ganze war heute recht spontan muss ich
sagen normalerweise wärst du bei mir zu
Gast bei zu Gast bei Sally challenges
Karaoke ich lerne was von dir
also wenn du den Tag heute überstehst
wir haben uns gedacht wie so eine Art
wie sagt man da ja so ein bewerbungstag
wenn du es heute überstehst dann kannst
du gerne noch mal kommen und du sagst
mir was ich tun soll ich bin ich mache
alles ich bin ganz klare sozusagen in
der Küche
weil dann kriegt er wirklich jeder
also erste Frage magst du Kuchen ja
sehr magst du Streuselkuchen sehr und
zwar habe ich mal vor ein paar Jahren
und Streuselkuchen gemacht mit
Kirschfüllung und meine Community hat
den tatsächlich abgewandelt ich habe da
so eine Facebook-Gruppe Leckereien aus
Sallys Welt also ist nicht meine das
haben Zuschauer gegründet und die haben
sich da das Rezept so ein bisschen
abgeändert und dann habe ich mir gedacht
hä voll cool inspiriert durch die
Community mache ich jetzt auch ein
Vanille Streuselkuchen sehr schön
also wie geht's los also los geht's mit
dem Pudding dafür verwenden wir 800
Milliliter Milch 4 Eigelbe 80 Gramm
Stärke 80 Gramm Zucker und etwas
Vanilleextrakt jetzt darfst du gerne
darfst Du die heute alles machen so
etwas Milch in den Topf
so ein bisschen ja das reicht schon und
jetzt eigentlich alle anderen Zutaten
rein und schön glatt rühren
ja bei mir muss immer ausgekratzt werden
ich bin kein lebensmittelverschwenderin
bei mir ist immer alles bis zum letzten
Rest
jetzt immer schön schön ausgekratzt
sauber ja das habe ich von meinem Papa
mein Papa hat immer alles dazu kann
Marmeladengläser wenn sie leer waren hat
er dann mit seinem Tee noch ausgespült
ja ganz ganz sparsam ist gut
effizient ich lass mal kurz unsere Katze
rein ja wie heißt die Katze Muffin
ich koche manchmal ja aber
normalerweise nackt
unterstütze deswegen dachte heute ziehe
ich mir mal was anderes
aber ich will jetzt nicht dass später
mein Team dann sagt hier Belästigung am
Arbeitsplatz also ich habe wirklich ein
paar YouTube-Videos gemacht aber ich
wirklich nackt und es war so unangenehm
das zu produzieren weil also
lustig fand erst und dann habe ich es
bereut aber dann waren die ersten zwei
Videos also dann muss man ja durchziehen
und
es war echt unangenehm dass die
produzieren wir selber also wir haben
das
war vor allem ja das war schon nicht
okay ich kriege das gar nicht richtig
glatt
wir streichen später durch den Sieb
ich glaube dass der erste Kuchen den ich
je in meinem Leben wirklich Backe was
ich bin überhaupt kein Bäcker okay Grill
gerne ich koche sonst irgendeinen Zeug
ja
dein Lieblingskuchen
mit so einem ein bisschen
Kirschsoße so eingearbeitet so ein
buttrige geile saftige Kruste die
zuckerbutter und Zucker und Butter
und dann ist das so amerikanisch
weil deutscher Käsekuchen ist der Shop
ist
es okay oder soll ich weitermachen
direkt auf dem Herd erhitzen gibt es
eine schneebesenablage auch
nicht laufen
was ist das so eine matte damit das
nicht wegrutscht aber da geht die
Induktion geht durch
und viele haben ja ein Problem damit
wenn der Herd verkratzt also ich jetzt
nicht aber viele zu Hause
wie neu
und es geht aber nur auf der
induktionsmatte weil normales Ceranfeld
wird dir heiß deswegen geht es dann
nicht ja trotzdem schön durch und man
hat halt die eine Hand frei war und
immer
natürlich schlau
ist während du backst normalerweise ja
kommen wir machen jetzt meine
hallo wir machen heute einen Kuchen ich
koche gerade die Milch auf mit ein
bisschen eigelb und Zucker und das ganze
Rezept gibt es bei Sally auf dem Kanal
und der Paul erklärt mir jetzt hier wie
man richtig Kuchen backt genau
[Musik]
von der Arbeit hier im cellicon Valley
Workout also sehr schaumig jetzt hier
was heißt denn ein dicken eigentlich
also einmal aufkocht und dann quasi
fester Pudding mit okay wir waren nicht
klar dass wir Pudding machen können
hier deckt es richtig ein
so richtig so ein schöner fester Pudding
und jetzt ich würde gerne runterstellen
kannst du mir das ein bisschen
runterstellen ich habe Angst ich will
jetzt hier nichts kaputt machen deswegen
dass ich das Schaum noch verbindet
[Musik]
ist der Topf dreckig von draußen ich
glaube das magst du nicht so so
kannst du das ertragen
selber gar nicht so so ich also ich
würde jetzt ausmachen hier
[Musik]
oh nein habe jetzt echt verschüttet muss
lag jetzt nicht
[Musik]
den Pudding streichen wir durch und sie
warum damit die Klümpchen verschwinden
hey ich habe doch so gut gesagt keine
Klümpchen drin
ja komm doch so gut gerührt
wir lassen den wir lassen den so das
sieht gut aus aber du willst
normalerweise durch den Sieb streichen
damit das noch mal ein bisschen feiner
wird okay
aber das sieht echt gut aus
wir füllen ihn nur um dass er schneller
abkühlt
zwischendrin hast du den ausstreicher
schon sauber gemacht habe ich genau
gesehen stark
okay aber ich bin schon froh dass der
dass der Pudding nicht angebrannt ist
weil normalerweise tendiere ich dazu
dass sowas bei mir anbrennt
weil die meisten denen auf zu hoher
Hitze kochen und die soll ich ehrlich zu
dir sein ich habe mich sehr gewundert
warum die Hitze so gering war und ob du
das machst um mich zu ärgern weil ich
dachte damit ich länger da rühren muss
damit es nicht lange ich jetzt sofort
hochgestellt am Anfang habe mich aber
nicht getraut und das Ding ist noch dass
die meisten keine guten Töpfe haben
also wäre das akzeptabel okay
ich hatte noch nie so einen richtig
schönen cremigen Pudding den hat er ja
fabelhaft exzellent gerührt ja also
verarscht mich oder bist du zufrieden
mit meiner Pudding
ja und die meisten Menschen haben Töpfe
mit so einem Sandwichboden kennst du
Töpfe die unten so ein Absatz und das
ist eigentlich weil der Topf so eine
günstige Produktion ist und die Hitze
nicht gut verteilt dann packen die da so
ein Sandwichboden hin damit der noch
okay der Boden heißt und der Rand nicht
das heißt die Milch kocht nicht aber der
Boden brennt an die topfqualität ist
also entscheidend für die klumpigkeit
des Puddings und die das nicht anbrennen
und habt ihr gute Töpfe bei euch im Shop
sehr schön wir entwickeln gerade neue
Edelstahltöpfe habe ich gesehen oben ich
war nämlich in der
Produktionsentwicklung die sehen nicht
nur gut aus die waren auch schwer weil
gute Qualität fünffach ne fünffacher
Stahl
made in Germany
beeindruckend sehr schön so was machen
wir jetzt mit dem Pudding der soll jetzt
Abkühlen wir einfach zur Seite ne wir
machen keinen Deckel wir rühren immer
mal wieder drum wer möchte kann jetzt
natürlich auch ein Schokopudding draus
machen ganz einfach 100 Gramm
Zartbitterschokolade einrühren
fertigpudding damit die Community wieder
statt Milch einfach Kirschsaft
so dann haben wir hier schon die Zutaten
für den Mürbeteig denn wir machen jetzt
einen Teig der ist für den Boden und für
die Streusel sehr praktisch bist du so
Streusel im Streusel Mensch
Streusel Hosen Streusel Streuselschnecke
in der großen Pause bei mir gab es ein
Schweizer das war so ein Käsebrötchen
und Streuselschnecke ja Streuselschnecke
oder Streuselschnecke mit bitte ja oder
bei mir weiß auch was ich immer Lust
hatte echt immer die ganze Schulzeit
über da gab es diese weißen
kaiserbrötchen mit Wurst aber ich durfte
die halt nicht essen weil schreiben
und dann musste ich mich mit
Laugenbrötchen entweder hatte ich Glück
und es gab käselauge oder ich hatte kein
Glück und es gab nur Lauge und dazu ein
Apfel immer einmal apfelabweisung einmal
Lauge abweisen und das zusammen Essen
wirklich ja
also klingt okay ich werde es
ausprobieren und das Laugenbrötchen ist
aber trocken also nicht belegt
aber die gibt's ja heute es gibt heute
ja na klar
wir vermengen die Zutaten
also für den 123 Teig nehmen wir 130
Gramm Zucker 260 Gramm kalte Butter 390
Gramm Mehl etwas Salz Vanilleextrakt
später noch ein Eigelb und zum Bestreuen
Mandelsplitter
heißt wirklich eins zwei drei warum
130 Zucker 260 Butter und 390 Mehl okay
123 gut
also eigentlich wird der Teig nur aus
den drei Zutaten bestehen aber für den
Geschmack ist ein bisschen Salz immer
wichtig und Vanilleextrakt und später
für die Bindung Eigelb jetzt werden wir
es so machen in crumble ist immer
wichtig dass kein Eigelb drin ist denn
crumble die müssen richtig mürbe sein
deswegen geben wir erstmal diese Zutaten
hier rein genau
die Butter zerstückeln war ein bisschen
so in der Schale kannst du ich habe
Hände gewaschen
ich habe gerade eben gesehen wie du
Hände wäscht ich habe noch nie jemanden
so schnell Händewaschen sehen das war
ein Ablauf von also wenn Sie jemals eine
Weltmeisterschaft im Händewaschen gibt
dann solltest du dich da anmelden das
war das war
der Vorgang Wasser Seife ne etwas sehr
lange dann aber wie schnell kannst du es
einmal
es war voll schneller muss ich sagen
ach so dann habe ich bestimmt so gemacht
warte dann weiß ich habe da etwas
Pudding
so
mir aufgefallen beeindruckend ich war
schon mal die Hände obwohl ich das schon
das ist nicht so gut geklappt
mich auch nie voll tatsächlich
[Musik]
ich muss jetzt sauber gemacht werden
oder
so jetzt machen wir den Teig an genau
gemacht worden von was ist denn die
Maschine von Kenwood ist die gut die ist
sehr gut jetzt auch eine integrierte
Waage also wenn ich privat koche ohne
Kamera wiege ich immer alles da rein
okay aber ich habe jetzt noch keine
Küchenmaschine soll ich mir die kaufen
gibt es ja gerade ein Angebot vielleicht
ja klar
was kostet denn ich glaube 1.200 mit
Komplettpaket
die kann kochen die kann Frittieren die
kann hier oben rühraufsätze die kann
Smoothies die kann da vorne nudelwalze
die kann wirklich alles ich kenne diese
andere so automatisiert ich weiß gar
nicht wie die heißt das ist besser viel
besser weil hier hast du halt mehr
Funktionen drin für den gleichen Preis
ist schon Induktion bis 180 Grad
und Popcorn willst du Popcorn isst du
gerne
die sieht auch ziemlich geil aus die
Maschine oder bedient man das dann jetzt
was für ein Programm mache ich die war
früher selber und dann habe ich meine
lackiert mit Autolack in schwarz und
habe Kenwood gesagt ihr müsst die
Hersteller nee wir machen keine schwarze
dann habe ich gesagt einfach den
Hintergrund gestellt weil sind alle
hinter Community abgegangen und da
mussten sie eine schwarze machen gut so
und jetzt haben sie einen Preis dafür
bekommen wer nicht hören will muss
fühlen würde ich da mal sagen
was steht hier in der Mitte was soll ich
machen für ein Programm genau Mitte dann
einmal da unten drehen wo auf zwei
ja und dann einfach drücken
manueller Modus das ist ja relativ
einfach zu bedienen die Programme
was wir nicht vergessen dürfen während
die ein bisschen rührt nehmt euch den
Pudding damit er keine Haut entsteht und
wird den bisschen ums fast schon zu spät
was macht man da wenn Haut entstanden
ist streichen aber wir wollen es ja
vermeiden kommen wir rühren den einfach
weiter das merkt doch am Ende keiner
ich werde nie vergessen wie wir uns das
erste Mal kennengelernt haben in meinem
Garten ich habe eine Gartenparty gemacht
ihr kamt ein bisschen zu spät weil
irgendeine anladung davor hattet die
Party war schon weg ja ich habe auch
erst um 16 Uhr eingeladen für 18 Uhr
aber hier kam vorbei was ich mega geil
fand und es war großartig aber du bist
in den Garten reingekommen da waren 23
Leute am Feiern fünf davon Köche sehr
viel Wein schon geschlossen es war schon
was auch immer Sally kommt rein in den
Garten sagt hier sieht es ja aus wie Sau
fängt als allererstes an aufzuräumen die
Küche einmal so zwei drei überflogen
es war positiv es war einfach so
ich kann da so ein bisschen hier du hast
sehr geholfen das war und du hast bei
meinem Team glaube ich inspiriert weil
am nächsten Morgen ich habe ja dann doch
ein bisschen viel Wein getrunken und bin
irgendwann eingeschlafen
und bin dann vielleicht kurz
eingeschlafen während der Party und am
nächsten morgen bin ich aufgewacht und
zwar alles aufgeräumt und mein Team
gesehen hat wie du das machst mit
Beispiel voran und haben gesagt dann
machen wir das jetzt auch danach und
dann haben die sich hingesetzt und haben
danach aufgeräumt so nämlich vielen Dank
Franzi und Simon vielen Dank fertig
danke
ja und zwar nehmen wir jetzt ein
bisschen Streusel raus für oben drauf am
Ende
wie viel
[Applaus]
kannst auch noch eine zweite Sache sehr
sehr gut also es ist bei uns im
Freundeskreis wird es oft zitiert
die Playlist du hast dein Handy
angeschlossen oder hast gesagt wir
machen jetzt Musik dann hast eine Wand
23 Leute zu Gast im Garten und 23 Leute
haben getanzt stundenlang zu Sallys
playlist
Britney Spears let's get loud ach nee
stimmt
natürlich und danach kommen Britney
Spears die Backstreet Boys aber bei ABBA
war manche so okay ernst
es war die ganze Zeit Ernst also aber es
war riesen geil also es hat ja wirklich
einfach mal gemeinsamer Nenner
noch da
jetzt habe ich ein echtes Problem wie
schaffe ich den ausschaber aus
automatisch richtig gemacht
meine kinder hassen auch meine
Teigschaber ich lasse nämlich nie was
übrig ich nasch nicht beim Backen
darfst du nicht
weil ich dann gar keine Lust mehr
zu viel
einfacher
und dann hole ich das schon
damit kann ich auch das Eigelb raus
haben ich bin einfach dafür dass wir
diese Sendung ungeschnitten lassen ich
mein i'm sorry aber wir sind halt echt
zusammen echt gut ich weiß gar was jetzt
wegschneiden wollt
viel Spaß
lass mal einfach eine Live-Sendung wie
wäre es mit einer live-sender
[Musik]
Küchenelement den ausschaber ausschalten
gutes Programm starten dann läuft die
einfach automatisch durch das ist ja
super einfach mit der Kennwort
Küchenmaschine von Sallys Welt
ich packt jetzt hier ein bisschen zur
Seite
dann ist das schon soweit dann mache ich
jetzt kurz sauber
[Musik]
warum machst du dir jetzt sauber weil da
von der Butter so ein bisschen
Fettflecken hier rechts waren und weil
ich du möchtest
visuelle ist dir schon auch wichtig sehr
wichtig genau also es ist sehr
beeindruckend weil du ja wirklich auch
ein sehr visuelles Auge hast also du wir
haben heute schon Fotos gemacht wir
haben heute schon Gartenartikel
angeschaut wir waren schon richtig aktiv
und überall schiebst du immer so ein
bisschen was rum du bist ein sehr
visuell denkender Mensch das cool ich
vergessen den Pudding immer mal wieder
um zu rühren weil sonst kommt da eine
haut drauf und das wollen wir ja nicht
falls doch mal bei euch zu Hause eine
dolle Haut entstanden ist weil
vielleicht die Kinder im Haushalt oder
sowas das was passiert die Katze dort
was auch immer und dann passiert ja
manchmal dass eine haut drauf ist
einfach ein Sieb nehmen durchst so mache
ich das immer bei mir zu Hause wenn ich
packe da entsteht dann keine Haut auf
dem Pudding
mein erster Kuchen
den ich meine Tochter passt sehr gut ich
habe eine elfjährige Tochter deren
größtes ist Backen also wenn die frei
wenn die euch ab Nachmittag frei und
dann fragst Du sie was würdest du gerne
machen sofort immer Backen das ist das
einzige was sie wird bei euch daheim
gebacken
und also wir wurden in Amerika und da
ist es schon so dass das so die
europäische deutsche also das Essen wird
da hoch angesehen weil über die
amerikanische Küche ja doch noch mal
sehr viel umso mehr ist dementsprechend
erpacken wir sehr viel und aber es ist
eine richtige Sauerei wenn meine Tochter
backt das hat sie noch nicht so richtig
kann ich dir mal hier vorbeischicken
dass die lernt aufzuräumen deswegen das
sage ich auch immer auf Messen
tatsächlich wenn man unterwegs und ich
fahre Publikum wackelt dann sage ich
auch immer meine Mutter und das ist
glaube ich was mich geprägt hat meine
Mutter hat gesagt du darfst in der Küche
machen was du willst kochen und backen
wir kaufen alle Zutaten aber macht die
Küche sauber und das ist bei mir glaube
ich so der Tick der ist so ein bisschen
hängen geblieben weil ich weiß ich darf
nur kochen machen wenn anschließend
sauber ist und währenddessen jetzt nehme
ich den Teig da kommt hier rein wir
haben eine kreisrunde Form vorbereitet
einfach auch ein bisschen Backpapier das
Backpapier war ein bisschen größer als
die Form und dann von oben rein gedrückt
damit man an den Randen an dem Rand des
so hoch geht ja ist das ein
wiederverwendbares Backpapier
tatsächlich also es war früher habe ich
welches benutzt was kompostierbar war
das fand ich aber eben nicht gut
deswegen das echte nachhaltigkeit ist
wenn man Produkte kauft konsumiert und
benutzt die man öfter benutzen ich liebe
deine Denkweise sehr gut ja
das heißt und wie kann ich das
Wiederverwenden du ist zum Abspülen gibt
es einfach die Spülmaschine rein
jetzt bin ich tatsächlich ein bisschen
überfordert ich mach den einfach da rein
einfach mal da rein
[Applaus]
in die Spülmaschine das ist sehr
praktisch das darf da rein okay
ich bin beeindruckt ich bin beeindruckt
wie gut du hier in der Küche bist soll
ich den Schaber auch schon mal
reinmachen damit wir den sauber haben
für später ist es ein ausschaber das ist
richtige Produkt der Teigkarte gibt's
die bei euch im Shop die Teigkarte
sehr gut sehr schön okay das sieht jetzt
erstmal nach einem Unfall aus ne aber
das richten wir jetzt gleich her guck
mal und zwar nimmst du das ist ein
ausroller
weißt du noch vorhin am 3D-Drucker der
das komisch schwarzen lange Ding das ist
der Griff vom ausroller und gibt es denn
bei euch im Shop okay und das Produkt
ist ein Teig ausroller warum ist der
schief weil ich weiß nicht ob früher bei
euch daheim gebacken wurde und früher
gab es diese Teigroller die sahen aber
anders aus die hatten so ein Holz gegen
vorne dran so eine Holzrolle da klebt
aber alles dran deswegen ist das auch
Silikon und konisch geformt damit man
damit bis an Rand kommt und der Teig
wenn du das nicht konisch geformt hast
das machen so viele falsch und das so
gerade ist dann dann stoppt es immer und
wenn es komisch ist dann drückt den Teig
so an Rand ich habe zum ersten Mal
chronisch geformt aber sehr genial also
das werde ich jetzt oft sagen also
chronisch heißt dass es ein Kegel ist
aber nicht ganz im Kegel nicht ganz also
ich hatte lerne ein komisch geformter
Teig den gibt es bei euch im Shop
nicht da deswegen müssen wir leider den
nehmen damit Rolle ich jetzt den Hund
und die Wurst die drücken wir hier an
Rand dann haben wir nämlich einen
schönen Rand gleich das machen wir aber
ganz drumherum genau mit den Händen wenn
ihr irgendwelche Fragen habt könnt ihr
die gerne hier unten stellen in den
Comments und dann beantwortet Sally oder
ich die offenen Fragen
und alle weiteren Fragen an mich
[Musik]
also eins zwei drei Teig der ist auch
eine Basis für andere Kuchen was denn
zum Beispiel
alles was quasi so einen festen
Mürbeteigboden hat ja oder Plätzchen ist
auch ein Plätzchenteig okay
jetzt kommt der Roller zum Einsatz der
chronisch geformte Teigroller ein
bisschen einfacher zu machen kannst du
das jetzt nehmen und einmal so eine
Kugel das ist nicht so Acryl
wusstest du dass das auf Netflix die
meist also das weibliche Netflix nutze
vor allem diese ganzen Mörder Dokus ich
kann die Dinge nur sehen und lesen wenn
sie nicht echt sind ich habe damals
angefangen
das kann ich nicht Zeit weil Murat mir
dann gesagt hat den gab es wirklich und
dann habe ich das Ganze online
durchgelesen und das kann ich dann nicht
anschauen ich konnte es nicht weiter
gucken es triggert mich schon bisschen
ich würde schon gern aber ich kann es
natürlich der Typ war ja so furchtbar
ekelhaft so widerlich und ich kann sowas
nur wenn es fiktiv ist deswegen kann ich
Fitzek Bücher lesen okay
sehr schön wie kann ich jetzt hier genau
ich bin ein bisschen Mehl so ein
bisschen das drücken wir so ein bisschen
im Handballen flach macht ein bisschen
leichter und jetzt so ganz vorsichtig
ohne zu viel Druck
[Musik]
für Scanner barfuß was passiert ich
glaube da kriegst du ein Herzinfarkt
ich bin gerade barfuß im Stück Teig
getreten am Fuß ist Teig
gibt sonst irgendwas was du nicht was du
physisch nicht ertragen kannst also
sonst fliehen so eine so eine
zwangneurose oder sowas ich habe doch
gerade jetzt
ein bisschen
[Musik]
also ich habe es einfach genommen
er aber guck mal das ist doch hier zu
dick
zu dünn oder also hier am Rand müssen
wir mal gucken
das ist dann gut und damit der jetzt
oben schön ist guck jetzt kannst Du eben
dieses Messer
bist du streng auch manchmal ja
ich mag es halt gern
ich finde es aber wirklich sehr gut
also was wirklich genial ist wie viele
neue Produkte ich hier kennenlernen ich
liebe Produkte und ich liebe wir machen
auch manchmal auf Instagram das Produkte
des Tages oder der Woche wo man so
verrückte Maschinen und so weiter
letztens habe ich einen einen Halter für
Müllbeutel fürs Auto mit so zwei
Saugnäpfen wo man quasi Müllbeutel
reinmachen kann wenn man irgendwie
Campen geht oder irgendwas
warum machen Autohersteller das nicht
und deswegen und ich habe hier schon so
viel coole neue Produkte und also das
zum Beispiel finde ich extrem gut wenn
man jetzt nicht wüsste dass es irgendwas
mit backen zu tun hat also muss aber
dann darf halt nicht heute gepostet oder
was auch immer dass man irgendwann das
jetzt posten würde und sagen würde was
kann das wohl sein
bist du jemand der Früchte in Kuchen und
Torten macht ja ich bin ein
früchtebefürworter also wenn ihr wollt
tatsächlich könnt ihr hier drunter gerne
noch so eine bratapfelschicht machen
bist du Bratapfel
okay dann soll der Murat jetzt nämlich
die Äpfel aus dem Garten holen dann
machen wir noch Bratapfel dazu aber
es tut mir leid es ist okay ich dachte
ich habe ganz
ich habe auch den Aufsatz nicht gefunden
Gott sei Dank haben wir jetzt noch
crumbles die machen den Kuchen nämlich
perfekt
ich arbeite immer ich will auch also ich
das ist mein Produkt des Tages bisher
der ausstreicher mit dem ausstreicher
Vorrichtung das ist da die löffelablage
ohne Scheiß ich habe mich jetzt jedes
Mal gefreut dass ich die da hinstellen
kann
die kaufe ich mir jetzt sofort gibt es
ja auch einen anderen Farben
für dich nur in pink aber für alle
anderen gibt es die in allen Farben ja
man kannst du jetzt die streuselchen da
drauf verteilen
zum ersten Mal das weiß ich eigentlich
nicht oder doch also Angst im Leben
ja 100%
. welche immer so Zacke deswegen
wegen deiner Persönlichkeit ein bisschen
einfach also ich habe Respekt gesunden
Respekt ja also Angst ist ja nicht ich
meine das ist viel zu negativ ja weil du
gerade ein Messer in der Hand hattest
zum Beispiel weil du schon auch ein
bisschen verrückt bist ja also sehr
positiv verrückt alle also sehr viele
Leute sind ja verrückt sagen wir mal so
und haben daraus was gemacht also knossi
ist genauso verrückt oder Karo Kauer
oder Campino oder wie sie alle heißen
die die sind ja alle nicht ganz dicht
ich auch ich bin überhaupt nicht dick
genau aber deswegen muss man immer
aufpassen mit solchen Leuten weil die
irgendwann was Verrücktes machen und
deswegen habe ich also ich habe jetzt
keine Angst dass ich hier heute sterbe
aber es wäre jetzt schon möglich dass
hier irgendwie über mir Schleim auf
einmal auf mich drauf liegt oder sowas
also das sehe ich in der Realität so
aber zurück zu unserem
Kuchen natürlich bist du lieb aber ich
kann nur sein dass du gleich auf einer
Karaoke Bühne stehen davor das muss ich
sagen kann ich überhaupt nicht hasse es
richtig ich überhaupt nicht singen kann
und das ist richtig das ist richtig out
of Minecraft Song also da
hätte ich echt Probleme
okay also ein bisschen angetrunken dann
ja hey wir haben noch getanzt im Garten
und aber ja
einfach drauf
das sieht super aus und jetzt schön
verteilen Mandeln noch drüber fertig
fertig ist der Kuchen gibt es ein
streuselverteiler in eurem Programm nee
leider man könnte jetzt den tortenkamen
dafür benutzen ja das würde ich gerne
hast du einen tortenkamera
ich würde den erst fein gezackt also
beide damit man mit dem fein gezackten
erstmal ein bisschen Struktur reinbringt
und dann mit dem grob gezackten am Ende
noch mal mag ich ja super
[Gelächter]
ist tatsächlich gut dafür super hier als
tagespraktikant heute morgen habe ich
schon fotografiert
später mache ich noch den Hof sauber
und Berufsbezeichnung ist dann
eierlegende wollmixer weil er einfach
alles kann er kann alles
kann ich nicht aber so ein bisschen
alles ein bisschen ich tue so
tatsächlich also ich bin
also ich bin immer nach Amerika jetzt
gekommen damit indem ich immer so tue
als ob ich irgendwas weiß und kann also
auch ganz oft behaupte ich irgendwas
einfach weil sie überhaupt nicht weiß
aber wenn man das überzeugend darstellt
dann funktioniert es total also wenn man
einfach dass das hinkriegt dass man
irgendwie also zum Beispiel war so dass
ich erst Medizin studiert habe und ja in
Heidelberg weil mein Vater Arzt und
deswegen dachte ich es Medizin gut und
ich habe das fertig studiert und dachte
dann aber dass ich eigentlich nicht als
Arzt arbeiten will sondern eher so
businessmäßigen habe dann BWL studiert
sozusagen dazu nichts davon stimmt was
ich gerade gesagt habe
aber ich habe das mit BWL Studium
gelesen das ist aber nicht fertig
nicht fertig
wo kommen die Mandeln drauf auch auf den
Kuchen jetzt ja und du wolltest was von
Murat erzählen dass er auch manchmal
behauptet ja was heißt behauptet er ist
dann auch sei überzeugt er hat zum
Beispiel ganz früh also nicht ganz am
Anfang meiner Youtube Zeit weil da
wollte dann nichts zu tun haben aber
irgendwann hat er gesagt Sallys Channel
Sallys future ist der größte foodshell
den es gibt da war es halt auch nicht so
aber dann wird so talkit into existence
heißt das
einfach davon überzeugt dass es so sein
wird
müssen auch nicht alle drauf also jetzt
so die Hälfte davon passt ich habe den
nicht abgewogen
dafür können wir die kenwood-maschine
stellen und dann ablegen sozusagen
einmal auf Null stellen
ist der vorgeheizt der Backofen also
normalerweise würde ich ihn vorheizen ja
auf wer kommt dazu besucht deine Eltern
hallo wir wollen sie gleich mal rein wir
haben alle Spachtel sauber
musste sich Ärger mit deinem Vater
kriegt dass ich hier was verschwende
oder sowas
ja kann schreien lassen 190 Grad ober
Unterhitze aber wir backen jetzt mit
backsensor dann macht der Backofen alles
alleine ist er von Bosch okay kannst du
sogar mit der Sallys Welt App connecten
und dann sagt er jetzt
musst du nichts mehr machen
ich bin fassungslos was es gibt dann
gehen wir auf Menü
gehen auf Kuchen
dann Kuchen Kuchen in Form Kuchen auf
Blech okay
noch Bratapfel machen und dann probieren
wir den wenn er fertig ist
[Musik]
okay Äpfel sind geschnitten Zucker ist
karamellisiert hier
schöne Bratapfel Weihnachtsstimmung hier
weißt du was ich noch mag sind
[Musik]
Preiselbeeren
Preiselbeeren Cranberries wie auch immer
man sie nennt nicht so viel gemacht
bisher ich habe es immer gezuckert für
eine schöne Deko
machen
ein bisschen Wasser auf brauchen
bisschen Flüssigkeit
und wenn du noch hast zur Verbindung
hast du ein bisschen Vanilleextrakt
merkst du
einfach zu viel Wasserdampf
okay
ein bisschen süßem Schnee fertig ist
unser Backrezept
vielen Dank für die hilfreichen Tipps
und Tricks ich habe von dir gelernt
heute die bis hin
hast du zufällig so ein Bunsenbrenner
vielleicht kriegst du es ja sogar
flambiert mit ein bisschen Zucker
das ist so ja
super geredet oder ich lieber wo unsere
Shop
aber nicht von mir nicht mein eigenes
Produkt ich habe keinen Bunsenbrenner
erfunden
ich würde ja mal am liebsten einfach so
ein ich habe eine Steinplatte wie meine
Physiklehrer damals Alkohol auf die
Arbeitsplatte und
so ein bisschen auf die Cranberries das
heißt wir sind durch und jetzt kann man
es eigentlich runterstellen lassen und
einfach ein bisschen einkochen
[Musik]
bist du zufrieden so jetzt ist er fertig
mit der backautomatik haben wir das zu
Ende gebacken und wichtig ist halt dass
da komplett abkühlt bevor man ihn
anschneidet am besten schon so zwei drei
Stunden okay deswegen einfach draußen
stehen lassen willst du anschneiden darf
ich anschneiden ja ist das ein
kuchenschneider Ja
kuchenheber und kuchenschneider schön
wird auch kein Druck auf dich aufbauen
aber der Kuchen wird er danach
fotografiert
wie schneide ich denn optimalen Kuchen
als Stück finde ich aber
okay und dann mache ich so rein und
runter und am Rand ein bisschen
aufpassen weil manchmal bricht der am
Rand deswegen darf ich schon ein
bisschen vorsichtig aber mach ruhig und
sägebewegung oder drückbewegung
ich nehme wir nehmen natürlich den
kuchenschneider so ein bisschen könnte
schwierig werden mit dem Mürbeteig
jetzt auch nicht unnötig große heraus
und dann schneidest du in den Schnitt
vom Schnitt geschnitten
das macht doch nicht zum ersten Mal doch
absolut Angst dass ich jetzt auf den
letzten Metern verzocke okay jetzt nehme
ich den kuchenheber
und hebe ein Stück auf den Teller
komm ist wirklich gut geworden
[Musik]
Produkt ist fertig
machen wir ein Foto gleich aber das
können wir jetzt probieren ja
beide gleichzeitig
aber ein bisschen was von dem Zeug noch
dazu ja
okay warte und es wird gerade echt
kompliziert
ich bin gespannt auf dir der
Vanillepudding Streuselkuchen mit Äpfeln
und Cranberries mit
dem warmen Bratapfel
sehr genial mit dem warmen
zehn von zehn
das Rezept gibt so
natürlich und in der App und ich würde
sagen du hast dein Tagespraktikum
bestanden wir gucken jetzt mal noch wie
er sich den Tag über hier so macht aber
dann würde ich mir sehr wünschen dass er
mal zu Gast ist bei zu Gast bei Sally da
können wir so richtig rausfordern den
Paul und falls ihr da schon Fragen an
ihn habt wie ich in challengen könnte
was ich mit dem anstellen könnte
Fragen von euch die euch interessieren
schreibt sie gerne in die Kommentare
dann werden wir das ganze demnächst mal
angehen
im November noch mal da ja
ich esse jetzt den Kuchen hier
den Rest fotografieren wir und dann sehr
gut super jetzt gehen wir noch ein
bisschen Gartenarbeit Haus habe Podcast
so Dinge die man halt noch so in unserer
Welt
noch die Küche sauber machen ne
tschüss
[Musik]